mesdames et messieurs ensemble nous
devons également nous saisir de la
question de
l'enfance je pense d'abord au rôle clé
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance c'est une
mission essentielle et je veux saluer
votre engagement pour pour l'animer et
en aucun cas je n'imagine que lesdas
faisait mieux que
vous
et je veux aussi saluer le travail
considérable des professionnels qui
accompagnent les jeunes au quotidien
collectivement nous pouvons nous devons
en effet leur rendre
hommage cependant toutes et tous vous me
faites part d'un diagnostic que je
partage laaz est un service public
structurellement en
tension d'abord comme vous je constate
que la contractualisation pour la
protection de l'enfance fonctionne et je
vous confirme que nous allons la
péréniser ensuite un comité
interministériel à l'enfance sera réunie
prochainement avec vous avec les
professionnels avec les ministres et
notamment Charlotte cobel nous y
prendrons de nouveaux engagements en
particulier en matière de santé ou de
scolarité des enfants
protégés je connais également votre
attente en matière d'insertion des
jeunes majeurs nous y travaillerons
ensemble
nous serons également très attentifs aux
conclusions de la mission sur l'enfance
et le handicap confié à Stéphane
aossouliier et Lucy
Carasco ces évolutions vous les attendez
mais il nous faut aussi aller plus vite
et plus loin ce que je vous propose
c'est une mobilisation générale pour
l'enfance
protégée comme vous le souhaitiez nous
lancerons prochainement une nouvelle
instance de dialogue associant les
ministres et les
départements une instance pour partager
ensemble un diagnostic des objectifs et
des
engagement chacun avec nos compétences
nos moyens et nos rôles nous devons
avancer dans le même sens pour les
enfants
protégés en outre dans certains
départements le soutien le dispositif de
soutien aux mineurs non accompagnés est
en tenstion aussi je vous annonce que
j'ai j'ai décidé de porter l'aide de
l'État au département à hauteur de 100
millions
d'euros au-delà des aspects financiers
j'entends vos
attentes notamment d'un cadre commun en
matière d'évaluation et d'une réduction
des délais de recours la réponse doit
être en effet collective
ensemble nous devons également nous
mobiliser pour les plus jeunes en 2023
nous avons créé le service public de la
petite enfance pour répondre aux besoins
des familles et assurer un accueil de
qualité à
[Musique]
chacun